Guy: Good morning,
and welcome
to this Android Accelerated
Rendering session.
Yes, Chet
worked really hard
on that sound effect
once again.
Haase:
[laughter]
Guy: And I believe, yeah,
if you want to tweet
because we're boring,
you have hashtags
at the bottom of the--
of the slide
that you can use so we can,
you know, see what
you are saying about us later.
If you have feedback,
there's this
incredibly-hard-to-parse link,
so go there, tell us what you
think about the presentation.
And, for those of you
who don't know me,
I'm Romain Guy.
I've been working on the
Android UI Toolkit team
for about four years now and,
on Android 3.0, I was in charge
of designing and implementing
the OpenGL pipeline
that we're going to talk about
in this presentation.
And joining me today
is Chet Haase,
who's been working
on animation
and was helping me
on the pipeline as well.
Haase: Oh, I thought
I was going to do this in mime.
Okay, so contrary to
popular belief,
we've actually been doing
GPU stuff for a long time.
People keep asking us for
GPU support for the platform.
We--we've actually got it
all over the place.
It just may not be
quite obvious to you.
For one thing, most of the games
are being written using the GPU,
either using the NDK,
OpenGL ES1 or OpenGL--
OpenGL ES2 are both
supported for the NDK,
or they could be using
the STK APIs,
which are basically wrappers
around those same libraries.
We also use it
for window compositing,
so we do software
rasterization of everything,
all the graphics
that we draw,
and that gets drawn
into a buffer
that is then composited
by the hardware,
so there's lots of GPU stuff
happening already.
Oh, and including
live wallpapers
which were written
with an earlier version
of Render Script,
which uses the GPU.
So there's all kinds of stuff
that's actually using the GPU.
However, the basic UI
is not using it.
So everything that we draw
on the screen in the framework
when--when you say
"Canvas.drawLine" or "Canvas."
you know, "drawRect,"
or, you know,
any of these shape operations,
all of the stuff that
the standard views are using.
That goes through
our Canvas APIs.
None of that stuff
is accelerated. Right?
And, on top of that,
the entire UI that you're using
in all the apps that--
that ship with the core platform
are not accelerated,
and that's kind of
what people mean,
is when is that stuff
going to get faster?
But, do we really need it?
Because all the CPUs
are getting faster,
the tablets are coming out
with multi-cores.
I mean, there's lots of devices
that are coming out
with faster CPUs,
more, bigger, better,
lots of memory to use,
multi-core,
so do we actually need
this thing accelerated,
because maybe we can
just depend upon the hardware
that we're getting
to speed it up for us.
Guy: And one of
the key differences
between tablets and phones
is that now we have--
we have much more pixels
onscreen,
and the difference
is pretty staggering, actually,
between a--a Nexus S
that has a high-density display
and the Motorola's tablet
that you see here
or the Samsung tablet that--
that you got yesterday.
I think we have more than
two times the amount of pixels
on the tablet and, you know,
now it's 2011
and you're expecting
richer experiences.
You want more animations
everywhere,
you want smoother animations,
and--
and just in general,
you know, you want the UI
to be perfectly smooth
and nice to use.
So here's the problem
that we've run into.
This is a little graphics--
a little graphic
that shows you the expansion
of the number of pixels
since the G1
that shipped in 2008
up until the Motorola Zoom
that shipped a couple month ago,
and that's the red line.
So you can see that between
the Nexus S and the Zoom,
we've seen a dramatic increase
in the number of pixels,
and the yellow line shows you
the available bandwidth
that we have
to move pixels around
between the CPU
and the memory,
and unfortunately, the bandwidth
itself has always been, like,
on par with
the number of pixels,
so it was good enough,
but now we have more pixels
than we can afford to move
on--on the bus.
So software rendering
is not enough.
So with Honeycomb,
we've introduced
a new rendering pipeline
for the UI,
so all the standard
drawing operations
that Chet mentioned
on the Canvas,
for instance "drawLine,"
"drawBitmap," "drawText,"
are now hardware accelerated
if you opt in,
and to give you an idea
of the level of compatibility
that we have,
all the standard applications
running on Android 3.0
are running
with this new pipeline.
So the browser,
which includes the web view,
Gmail, contacts, books,
they all run with hardware
acceleration turned on.
Haase: They--the acronym
that we have here
we're trying to popularize.
It's actually pronounced
"guh-poo-ee."
[laughter]
Haase: So it's--it's
user interface on the GPU.
That's the whole idea, so--
Guy: I'm sure
it will have a lot of success.
Haase: --you can start
using that today.
[laughter]
Haase:
So it helps to understand
how the rendering model
used to work,
and then how it works now
under this wonderful
new world
of GPU acceleration.
So in the releases
prior to 3.0,
a view would be redrawn.
So let's say a button
is being drawn and so
its onDraw method
gets called,
and then it calls
rendering operations,
it calls these drawing
operations on the Canvas API.
It's going to draw a border,
it's going to draw a background,
gradient fill,
or a bitmap,
it's going to draw
some text, whatever.
And then we go into
the software rasterizer.
We happen to use a library
internally called Skia,
and that basically turns
these operations into pixels
in the frame buffer.
So it, you know, does a little
Bresenham algorithm
or whatever it does,
and actually lights up the
pixels in the appropriate color
and then it gets copied
onto the display.
So all of that's
very straightforward.
In the new model,
we have this alternative way
of doing it instead.
So we go through
the same process
from the views perspective.
Nothing changes there.
The button's onDraw method
will get called,
it'll issue the rendering calls
into the Canvas API,
but instead of going through the
software rasterization route,
we go through
an alternative path
that turns those
into GPU operations,
essentially
calls into OpenGL.
So instead of walking
the line and--
and casting out pixels,
we say,
"Hey, OpenGL, why don't
you draw a line for us."
And this is basically the
pattern of all the operations,
all the GPU acceleration stuff
that we do,
and there's different ways
of doing it
that Romain
is about to talk about,
but basically everything
becomes a series of operations
that we send down to the GPU
via the OpenGL ES2 library.
Guy:
So with OpenGL,
the only primitives
we have available are points,
lines, triangles,
and textures.
I mean, it's a simplification
of OpenGL,
but that's pretty much
what we have to work with.
So we wanted to show you--
we wanted to give you a peek
behind the scenes, like,
what happens when we draw
some of the standard elements,
UI elements on Android.
So this is a simple ListView
running on Android 3.0,
and that list is turned into
a combination of those points,
lines, triangles, and textures
that I just mentioned.
So for instance,
that ListView,
once it goes through the OpenGL
pipeline, looks like this.
This is a screen shot I took
using one of our debugging tools
that shows us what exactly is--
is used by the GPU.
So you can see the mesh
that we're using to draw
all the icons,
the pieces of text,
and at the bottom of--
at the top and bottom
of the list,
you can see these
really wide rectangles.
Those are for the fade regions
that you see at the top
and bottom of the list
when you scroll them.
Haase: I actually like
this version better.
I think it's very geeky-cool.
You can't read the text
very well, but it--
it looks really neat.
[laughter]
Guy: It's--
it's a new style of UI.
Here's an example
of a button.
So we will ignore the text
in the--the--
the GPU transformation,
but a button uses something
we call "nine patches."
So nine patches
are pretty much textures
we stretch in--in--in--
in very specific ways,
and it's made
very easy by OpenGL
because we can just
map that texture onto a mesh
that looks like this,
and OpenGL will do
the work for us of stretching
the texture correctly.
The text itself is drawn
in a very similar way to path.
So here we have this beautiful
blue line with a--
with curves, and to render
a path like that,
what we do is we generate a--
an alpha texture, so--
so it's a mask.
And we apply this mask
on a very simple piece
of geometry, or quads.
We have only
two triangles.
And then with
our fragmentators,
we colorize the path.
So this is what
it looks like.
This is our mask.
This is the--the contents
of the OpenGL texture,
and we just draw it on top
of the simple piece of geometry.
And text is drawn
exactly the same way.
Our--our text--
this is a--
a very common way
of drawing text in GL.
You have this mask
that contains your font
and you just apply it on
very simple pieces of geometry.
For those of you geeks
who love OpenGL
and have used OpenGL before,
I just wanted to show you
a couple of the shaders that are
generated by the renderer,
and if you don't know anything
about OpenGL,
you probably don't care
about those next two slides,
so we won't go
into the details.
But, the--the--
one of the difficulties
of implementing the--
the OpenGL renderer was
we have so many different
combinations, you know,
API, that we could not write
all the shaders by hand,
so we have a--
a program that generates
those shaders at run time.
And I think we have, like,
several millions of combinations
of--of shaders possible.
So this is an example.
If you draw a piece of text
and you colorize
the inside of the text
with a gradient,
this is the vertex shader
that's generated by the--
the system.
And the vertex shader,
for those of you
who don't know that,
is applied to every single
vertex inside a mesh.
So with a triangle,
you have three vertices
and each vertex
runs this code.
This is the fragment shader.
Again, just an example.
You can see that we have
two textures.
Let me show you.
Two textures right here.
So that's the texture
that contains the font,
and that's the texture
that contains the gradient,
and the shader simply
combines them
into something
that looks awesome.
Haase: So obviously
this is really complicated stuff
and we did a lot of work
to make this work and--
and there's all these really
gnarly meshes being sent down
with texture maps and--
and complicated shaders.
So then the question is,
"How do you actually access it?"
What is the--
the complicated API
that you need
to be aware of
to enable hardware acceleration
in your applications?
So first of all--
no, actually that's it.
Basically, opt in.
The only trick
is that you need to choose
to have hardware acceleration
for your application,
because, as we'll get into
a little bit later,
there may be some stuff
that doesn't work quite--
quite correctly for you.
You may be using capabilities
of the Canvas API
that we simply haven't enabled
on the GPU at this time.
So you need to test
your application,
make sure it works for you,
and then go ahead and opt in
at the application level
by issuing this
in your manifest file.
There's a little bit more detail
to it than--than that,
which is that you can enable it
at the application level
or at the activity level,
or at the window level.
You can also disable it
at either the activity
or the application level.
And then, finally,
if your overall application
is running with hardware
acceleration enabled,
you can disable it for
particular views if you need to.
You can't enable it per view,
but once the application
has it running,
then you can disable it
per view,
and this turns out to be useful
for particular situations
where you really want
to use GPU acceleration
but your custom view clips
against a path
which is not currently
supported.
Well, what you can do
is just have that single view
use software rasterization.
Everything else
in your application
is happily using the GPU.
So here's a little bit
more detail
about how to actually opt
into this stuff.
So at the application level,
as I said,
you can opt in, say
"hardwareAccelerated = true."
Maybe there's
a particular activity
that can't use it
for some reason,
so you can disable it
at the activity label--
at--at the activity level
by setting the same flag
equal to "false."
You can actually see this
in the STK API demos.
There are some API demos
that used Canvas APIs
that were not accelerated at
the time that they were written,
so the activities opt out
by setting this flag to "false,"
even though
the overall application
is hardware accelerated.
And so you can also opt in
at run time on a window level
by setting this flag,
the "FLAG HARDWARE ACCELERATED"
flag.
And, finally, you can disable it
at the view level
by using a software layer.
We're going to learn more
about layers in a few minutes.
There's more to it
than simply being able
to disable hardware
acceleration for a view.
But, basically, if you want
to draw your view into a bitmap,
you can do this,
and that will use
software rasterization.
Guy: And if you plan on using
hardware acceleration,
you might run
into several issues
where you are using an API
that is not currently supported
by the pipeline,
so you might want to use
one of those two methods
to check whether
hardware acceleration
is currently enabled.
For instance, the team working
on the launcher application
for Android 3.0,
they wanted the code
to still be able to run
on our phones
that don't have hardware
acceleration at this time,
so their code contains
some of these checks to--
to perform some operations
in one situation and--and--
and some other operations
in the other case.
So for instance,
if the hardware acceleration
is on at the view level,
you might want to display,
you know, fancier graphics
or enable more animations,
but what's very important is to
check the hardware acceleration
at the Canvas level,
because even if your application
is hardware accelerated,
the Canvas that's patched
to your view for drawing
may be a software canvas.
If the view for some reason
is rendered into a bitmap,
then the view will be rendered
in software.
So just remember
those two methods.
You should not have to use them
in many situations.
I haven't used them myself in--
in any place,
I think, so far,
but it can be very useful.
And, like we mentioned,
we did not--
we do not cover 100%
of the existing 2-D API
with the hardware pipeline,
and there are various
reasons for that.
We had, you know,
time constraints,
there are some APIs
that are very rarely used,
if at all, by applications,
and there are also
some of the APIs
that we have on the Canvas
are difficult to implement
efficiently on the GPU so we--
we had to--to make a decision,
and some of these APIs
were left out.
Download that menu.
Haase: Yeah, it--it's important
to point out that,
before you get too worried
about all the stuff
that we don't support
on the GPU,
everything you see
on the tablets
that you got yesterday
is hardware accelerated
in the home screen,
the launcher,
the all apps view,
everything in the basic UI,
also everything
in the applications we ship,
so that's the level of support
that we have
for graphics acceleration,
you know.
Everything you're seeing
in contacts and Gmail
and YouTube and, you know,
all the API--all the--
all the UIs
for all these applications
in the home screen itself,
that's all supportable
by the GPU.
These are more like corner cases
that you should be aware of,
but won't run into with--
with the standard views
and probably won't run into
with your custom views either.
Guy: Yeah, if--if you use
the standard views
and the standard drawables,
you'll be fine.
So this is the complete list
of APIs we do not support
in Android 3.0
and I believe 3.1,
so when you clip, you can
only clip with the rectangles.
Clipping with "path"
and "regions"
is not currently supported.
Drawing pictures
is not supported,
although this--
this should be pretty easy
to add in the future.
DrawPoints was added either
in 3.1 or ICS,
I don't remember exactly,
but it's coming.
The DrawPosText and TextOnPath
are currently not supported,
but we probably will.
There's no technical reason
why we wouldn't.
DrawVertices is the same thing;
we can support it,
we just didn't have time
to do it.
And on the paints, you can't set
a MaskFilter or Rasterizer,
and I don't even remember
what the Rasterizer does,
so it's probably
not very useful.
Haase: Yeah, I think
it rasterizes.
Guy: I'm sure it does.
[laughter]
On top of that,
some of the supported APIs
have limitations.
So if you clip
with a rectangle
and you have a 3-D
transformation on the canvas,
the 3-D transform will not
be applied to the clipRect.
And there are some operations
that you can't do
on the clipRect.
You can't do an "x"
or a "difference"
or a "reverse difference."
Those are currently
not supported,
and I've never seen
an application use them.
DrawBitmapMesh, we ignored
the colors array at--
at--at this time.
Again, we can't support it.
DrawLines we don't have
anti-aliasing,
although ICS will add
support for that.
Haase: I--I hope so or else
I've been wasting my life
for the last three weeks.
Guy:
That was part of my plan.
Haase: [laughter]
Ha ha ha ha.
Guy: SetDrawFilter,
we completely ignore it,
and on the Paint,
if you try to use--
to enable dithering or to
disable filtering on bitmaps,
we ignore that.
We--those--those flags
are here to lower the quality
of the rendering,
which makes sense in software
because you want to save memory
and you want to save CPU time.
On the GPU,
we have enough horsepower
that we can always choose
the high-quality version.
And finally, shadows work
only on text at the moment.
And finally, there's this thing
called a "ComposeShader."
How many of you have ever used
a shader in--on Android?
Yeah, that's not many.
In a way, that's good,
but the other--you know--
Haase: I counted four.
Guy: Yeah.
Shame on you,
the other guys.
[laughter]
A ComposeShader lets you
combine two different shaders,
so if you want to draw
a gradient that's a shader,
if you want to draw--
to texture something,
you use a shader
and you can compose them
in one operation.
So the limitations we have
is that you can't recursively
use ComposeShaders,
and the two shaders
inside of ComposeShader
have to be of different types.
So you can't use two bitmap
shaders at the same time
or two linear or gradient
shaders.
And the workaround
for all these limitations,
pretty easy
if you have custom code
that uses any of these APIs,
or that requires any of
those limited functionalities.
Just use software layers
on your view.
And so we told you that you
should not worry too much about,
you know, the compatibility
of your app with the--
the--the rendering pipeline
because obviously it works for--
for--for--for very complex
applications that we ship,
but you have to be aware of--
of the--the new drawing model.
We--we had to make--
make some changes
to the rendering model that
exposed bugs in applications.
Those bugs were--
were actual bugs,
but they did not show up
as bugs onscreen,
so Chet will take you
through the new--
the old rendering model,
and the new rendering model,
and you will understand
what you should do,
and what you should not do
in your app.
Haase: So in the old
rendering model,
if a view changed--
so let's say, somebody--
you changed the text
on a button--
then internally we're going to
invalidate that view and--
and tell the system
that it needs to be redrawn.
If it's a custom view,
you--some property changes
and you call invalidate
on the view yourself.
Same model.
So the view gets invalidated,
and it propagates
that information up the tree.
It says, "Okay, parent,
I need to be invalidated.
You need to invalidate
yourself,"
and it walks all the way
up the tree to the ViewRoot,
and the ViewRoot says,
"Okay, things are invalid.
They need to be redrawn,
so I'm going to
tell the children
that need to be redrawn
to redraw themselves."
So we're going to tell
the parent to redraw itself
and then the parent redraws
its children,
and everything
is very happy.
Now, the--
the thing that we did
to make some of the GPU stuff
more efficient
was basically to not redraw
anything that hasn't changed.
So we created this thing
that we called "DisplayList,"
which is basically a cache
of the rendering operations
that are going to happen
for a particular view.
So there's no logic
in this thing,
it's just the rendering
operations themselves.
For a button,
there's going to be, you know,
drawing a border
or filling the background,
drawing the text,
whatever it is. Right?
So for instance, we can
take a look at the--the code.
This actually output from a--
a logcat
when we've got
a debug mode
where we can actually see
what the display lists are
to help chase
some issues down.
So we're saving a context,
and then we're drawing the patch
that the--
the button is using.
We're saving the context again
because we're about to change
some transform information.
We have a ClipRect.
We translate
to get to the interior
because we're
about to draw the--
the label itself
of the button,
and then we restore the contexts
that were saved.
So this is basically the way
all of our DisplayLists look,
is--is this list of commands
for any particular view,
and then if it's a parent,
it's going to be a list
of its drawing commands
and then all of the stuff
that references
to the DisplayList inside
the parent of--of the children.
So the new rendering model
looks like this.
You invalidate a view.
Something in the view changes,
you invalidate it.
That marks its
DisplayList "dirty."
Now, one of the things
to note here
is the parallel nature
of this thing,
so for every view, we have
a matching DisplayList.
So every view knows how
to draw itself with its--
its DisplayList.
So the view gets invalidated,
it marks its DisplayList
"dirty,"
which means, "My DisplayList
needs to be recreated."
It invalidates its parent.
Now, notice, the parent didn't
actually get dimmed out here
because the parent does not
need to be redrawn.
The parent simply needs
to redraw its children
which have changed.
Right?
So we're basically propagating
the information up the tree
to say, "Something in the tree
has been invalidated,
and it needs its DisplayList
recreated."
So the ViewRoot gets
this information and says,
"Okay, tree,
recreate the DisplayLists
that need to be recreated."
That does not recreate
the DisplayList
at the top for the ViewGroup,
it just recreates
the DisplayList
for the child
that got invalidated
and then it tells everybody
to draw
and that basically issues
the DisplayLists again,
which is a very quick operation
compared to actually
redrawing everything.
So notice the ViewGroup
didn't get redrawn here.
Instead, the ViewGroup
just issued its DisplayList
and the DisplayLists
of the children.
The only thing that got redrawn
was the actual view
that got invalidated.
Guy: And to better understand
why this is so important,
we're going to look
at a simple example.
So here, this is the--
the settings application
running on Android 3.0,
and we're going to just click
on the Wi-Fi setting list item,
and when you click--
when we click on this item,
it turns blue.
So now I'm going to show you
a simplified version
of what happened
before Android 3.0.
So just to turn that item blue,
we had to redraw everything
that intersected
with the list item.
That meant--that means that we
had to draw the background,
so the background texture
in the back of the window.
We had to redraw the panel;
there--
there was a gray panel
behind the list.
Then we had to redraw the--
the text selector.
We had to redraw the text
on top of--of the list item,
and then we had to redraw
the checkbox on the right.
And that is a lot
of code to run.
If you look at the source code
of the Android platform
and you go look at what's in
the drawing methods of ListView,
of TextView, you will see
there's a lot of logic.
It's not just simple, you know,
like, Canvas or drawLine.
There's a lot of--
of information there.
With the new model,
what you are able to do
is run only the drawing method
for the selector
because only the selector
turned blue
and then we can just callDraw
on the DisplayLists themselves.
So we run a lot less code
at the dyadic level
and then we can just run these
very simplified native list
of drawing commands in--
in native code.
Very fast.
So this is very important.
With the old model, if you
call invalidate on a view,
that view will redraw,
but if you call invalidate
on a view that intersects
with another view,
that other view
would also redraw.
And I've seen applications--
we run into this issue
internally
in some of our applications.
Our developers turned on
the hardware acceleration
and suddenly they had views
that would not redraw
because they were
relying on the fact
that by redrawing another view,
you know,
a second view
would draw as well.
With the new system,
we will only redraw views
on which you call invalidate,
and that was always
the contract.
The framework should
only redraw views
on which you call invalidate.
There was just
this weird side effect
that made it work in--
in that special case here.
So if you turn on
the hardware acceleration
on your application
and you have views
that suddenly don't refresh,
make sure you call
invalidate on--
on any view
that requires it.
And most of the time, you
don't have to worry about it.
If you change a view property
like the background drawable,
the text, the framework
will do it for you.
So most of the time, this issue
arises in custom views.
Haase: So an important case
of this is--
is worth understanding more.
It's not just views
that intersect,
it's also the parents that--
that get in the way here.
It used to be the case that
if you invalidated a parent,
your child
would get redrawn.
So if your custom view changed,
you could invalidate
the container it was in
and everything would get redrawn
and--
and life would be good.
In the new GPU model,
we do not redraw that view
because we haven't been told
that it changed.
We will redraw the parent,
and then the parent
will reissue the DisplayList
for the children.
So we can visualize this
by saying,
"Okay, we invalidate
the ViewGroup."
That gets dimmed out because
it's going to be recreated here.
That invalidates
all the way up.
ViewRoot says,
"Okay, redraw yourself,"
and the ViewGroup
happily does that.
I--actually,
this is the old model, right?
So it's actually going
to redraw the children and--
you know, life--
life was good.
I wanted to redraw
that view anyway, so--
so the correct thing
happened.
However, in the new model,
we now have these DisplayLists.
We invalidate the ViewGroup,
it marks its own DisplayList
"dirty,"
and invalidates all the way
up to the ViewRoot,
knows what to do next and it
says, "Okay, redraw yourself,"
and the ViewGroup happily
rebuilds its display list
and that's it.
Right?
It did not actually
rebuild the DisplayLists
of its children, which means if
one of those children changed,
we haven't done anything
to update the display of it
because we weren't told
that it changed.
This is a very important element
in getting the performance
that we needed
for the platform
because we really
don't want to do anything
that we absolutely
don't have to do.
It's one of the ways that we get
the performance that--
that we do on these devices.
Right?
So you need
to be aware of that
and construct your application
accordingly.
If you're using standard views,
they do the right thing.
They--they do invalidation
internally.
You do not need
to worry about that,
and in general, you're probably
doing the correct thing anyway,
but if you notice
that a custom view
is not actually
getting redrawn correctly,
then you might examine this
a little bit more closely.
Guy:
So we mentioned before,
software layers to work
around some of the limitations
of the hardware pipeline,
but we have other type--
another type of layers.
So we want to
talk about that
because they're
extremely useful.
So there's a new API on View
called "SetLayerType."
You can specify the type.
We have three different types,
and you can also pass in
optional Paint,
and we'll see what the--
the paint is used for,
but most of the time,
you'll probably pass No.
So even with the new model--
So here we have the example
of drawing a button.
So the button
has a DisplayList
and the DisplayList contains
a series of, you know,
drawing operations where
we save the--
the context, we draw a patch,
we draw the text, and so on.
But when we--we need to draw
the DisplayList,
we still need to run
a fair amount of code
at the OpenGL renderer level
to convert those--
those--those calls
into OpenGL code.
And that can be--that can be
a little bit too much
when you are trying,
for instance,
to animate very complex views,
like ListView.
So with layers, you can
think of layers as caches.
With layers, what we're going--
what we're going to do
is we're going to use
that DisplayList,
we're going to render it
inside this layer.
This will be, for instance,
an OpenGL text here.
And then when we need to
redraw the button onscreen,
if the button hasn't changed,
if you haven't called
invalidate on the button,
and you're only moving it,
we're simply going to
draw the layer itself.
So it's one operation,
it's very fast to do on the GPU.
And here are the three
types of layers.
We have the layer of "NONE."
This is the default value.
That means the view
does not have a layer.
We have the software layer
that we talked about.
So when you--
when you use a software layer,
the view will be rendered
into a bitmap.
So it will use the--
the old software rendering model
to render the view
inside the bitmap.
The bitmap
will then be converted
into an OpenGL texture,
and then will render
that texture onscreen.
Haase: That's basically
equivalent to what--
Guy: Yeah, they--
they use--used it--
Haase: --render cache.
Guy: Yeah, there's a--
an API called
"setDrawingCacheEnabled."
It does the exact
same thing.
And now we--and we also have
the hardware layer.
So the hardware layers
are very interesting
because we can use the GPU
to render the view inside an--
an OpenGL texture
and then we can render
the OpenGL textures--
texture with the GPU.
So it's extremely fast.
It costs GPU memory, but it's
something that we can afford.
The reason why you should use
these different types of layers,
we have several reasons.
The first one
is performance.
So if you need performance,
especially during animations,
you should use
hardware layers.
And we'll see an example
of how to--
on how to use them properly.
And to give you an idea
of how useful the--
the hardware layers can be,
this is a small comparison of
performance to draw a ListView.
So if we render a simple
ListView on Android 3.0--
3.0 using software,
it's going to take
about ten milliseconds,
which is way too much to get
nice, smooth frame rate.
If you use--if we use
DisplayList on the GPU,
it takes only two milliseconds,
but that's still a fair bit--
a fair amount of time
if you're moving, you know,
other complex views
onscreen at the same time.
And if we turn that--
that ListView inside the--
into a hardware layer,
it takes only a fraction
of a millisecond to do it.
So it's
extremely efficient.
Haase: Like, it's like
a factor of 1,000 speed-up
by using a hardware layer.
Guy: Tiny tiny fraction.
Haase: That's pretty cool.
Guy: Software layers
and hardware layers
can be used for
visual effects.
I mentioned before
the optional "Paint"
that you can pass
to the LayerType API,
and it can be used
to control how you blend,
how you composite
the layer onscreen.
So you can use it
to apply color filters,
for instance.
You can also apply
transparency,
and you can change
the blending mode.
So here I have
a screenshot
of a modified version
of the launcher.
So I modified the launcher
to apply one of those
special color filters
onto hardware layers.
When you go onto the All Apps
list in the launcher,
each page of your All Apps is--
is one hardware layer.
So all I had to do
was add a few lines of code
to turn the page
into a grayscale page.
Haase: This is the launcher
that came out in 1930s
before they had color.
[laughter]
Guy: Yeah.
Now we can afford colors.
So this is the code I added.
First, we--we created
a simple color matrix.
We set the saturation to "zero,"
then we create a new "Paint."
We set that color matrix
as a color filter,
and then, when we enabled
the hardware layer,
we just pass that Paint,
which means,
"When you draw that layer,
please set the saturation
to zero."
And that's all
you have to do.
Layers are also useful
for compatibility reasons.
We mention--
we mentioned it before.
Just use software layers
if you rely on stuff
that we do not support.
And animations--
if you use hardware layers
and software layers,
you can get really good
performance when animating,
and Chet will tell you
a little bit more about that.
Haase: So one of the things
that we did in 3.0
was to add a bunch of properties
to View.
This was as part of the work
that I was doing
on the animation framework.
The way that you used
to change properties
like the translucency of a view
was by using an AlphaAnimation,
which was nice if you wanted to
actually fade-in or fade-out,
but if you actually wanted
the view to just be translucent,
there was really no way
to do that without a--
a really sort of,
hacky workaround
of using an animation
as a side effect.
So we've actually put
properties on Views
where, frankly,
they belong.
So there's some very simple
properties
that effect the way
that a view is--is displayed.
There is the Alpha property
that affects the translucency,
there is some post-layout
translation properties,
so you can move the view
around within the layout
after the layout
positions it.
You can scale it,
you can rotate it,
including rotating it
around the "y" and "z"--
"y" and "x" axis
for 3D rotation,
and finally you can
declare the pivot point
around which scaling
and rotation happen.
So all of these properties
share the common attribute
that they are actually set
by the parent
prior to drawing
the view.
Now, the--the nuance there
that's important for animations
in the layers is that,
that means that the view
itself is not changing,
only the display attributes
of the view
that are handled
by the parent change.
Which means that if you draw
your view to a layer,
and then change the attribute,
well, that layer
can simply be copied
after the parent
sets the attribute.
So we can visualize this
a little bit here.
So if you set the rotation
"y" property, for instance,
you're going to rotate by
45 degrees around the "y-axis."
That invalidates
the parent.
Note that it didn't
invalidate the view itself.
The view knows that this is
one of those properties,
those magical properties,
that are actually handled
at the parent level.
So it says, "Hey, parent,
you need to be invalidated
and you need to recreate
your DisplayList and--
and reissue your childrens'
DisplayLists.
So the ViewGroup marks
its own DisplayList as "dirty"
and it gets recreated,
and everything happens.
It's all good.
So we can see the code
that actually happens
in the DisplayList level here.
The original DisplayList was
the ViewGroup drawing itself,
and then drawing the--
the DisplayList for "A"
and then drawing "B's" layer.
So if you "setRotationY"
then it's going to
reissue the DisplayList,
but before it does that,
it's going to set
the rotation property
and then reissue the layer.
And--and the key here
is that we didn't need
to recreate the DisplayList.
Right? So this could be
a really complicated view
that you have drawn
to a layer,
and then whenever
we need to redraw it,
all we need to do
is copy the layer,
which is an incredibly fast
operation on the GPU,
and that's how
we got the, you know,
three orders
of magnitude speed-up
on that ListView example
that we saw.
So we could touch
on the animation a little bit.
So this is--we're not
really going to get
into the animation
framework here.
There's articles
and presentations
about that you can
check out otherwise.
But, this is
a little bit of code
that animates
the "rotationY" property
using the new animation
framework in 3.0.
So what you want to do,
especially for complex views,
is set a hardware layer
temporarily. Right?
Layers
tend to be expensive
because they are
large objects,
so only use them
when you need them,
and in general,
probably use them temporarily
during an animation.
Guy:
They are also expensive
because if you would--
you might be tempted
to enable hardware layers
all the time,
but if you have a ListView
and you enable
the hardware layer
and the user starts
calling the list
on every frame
of this callAnimation,
we will redraw the list
into the hardware layer
and then we will draw
the hardware layer onscreen,
so we will--will be doing
twice the amount of work.
Haase:
Right.
So what you want to do
is to set the layer,
enable the layer,
and then run the animation.
But there's a little more to it
because then,
you want to disable the layer
when you're done.
So the way you do that
in the new animation framework
is by setting
the hardware layer,
declaring the animation.
So if you can't read
the animation code here,
it's basically saying,
"I'm going to create an
animation on the view "Object,"
I'm going to animate
the "rotationY" property,
and I'm going to animate it
to the value of 180 degrees."
We're going to add a listener
to the animation
so that we know
when the animation is done,
and then,
inside that listener,
we're going to
disable the layer.
We're going to set
the layer type to "none"
when the animation finishes,
and then we start the animation
when we're done.
Guy: And, so now we have
a few tips and tricks
that you should be aware of
if you plan on using
the new hardware
accelerated pipeline.
They're general tips and tricks
that you can also use
when you're doing
software rendering,
so the first one
is pretty obvious.
Don't use too many views.
The deeper your hierarchy
is going to be,
the harder it will be for
the system to render your--
your UI
in a very efficient way.
You can have really wide
view hierarchies,
as long as they are flat,
that's okay.
But, if they are really deep,
then it's going to be
very costly.
It's--again,
it's also an issue
when you're doing
software rendering.
It's even more of an issue when
you're doing software rendering
because we have to redraw
every single level
when we need to redraw,
like, one of the views
at the bottom of the tree.
So I gave a talk,
I think in 2009, at Google IO.
The presentation
is available on YouTube.
I--I gave--I explained
how you can, you know,
keep the number of views
to a minimal amount.
So you should refer to that talk
and make sure
that your application
does not use too many views.
Be very careful
of setAlpha.
So setAlpha
is this new property
that we've introduced
in Android 3.0.
It's really cool
'cause you can, you know,
change the translucency
of your view,
you can animate your view,
you can fade it in, fade it out.
The problem with setAlpha is,
if the view is not backed
by a layer--
software layer
or hardware layer--
we'll have to draw
the view twice.
We're going to first render
the view inside an--
an OpenGL texture,
and then we're going to render
that texture with the Alpha ID
that you gave us onscreen.
So that means
that we're going to have to
process twice
the amount of pixels.
We have really cool
optimizations
to minimize the amount of
blending that we're going to do,
but it will cost you twice the--
the fill-rate.
Haase: Reusing objects is
a good idea in general anyway,
especially if you're
inner loop,
and particularly if you're
running an inner loop
in an animation.
The VM is really good
at collecting garbage,
however, it does take
some effort. Right?
So if you're creating
a little bit of garbage
every time you're running it--
the animation frame
because your inner loop
is creating a new object,
and then you're
getting rid of it,
eventually you're
going to get a GC
and if that GC happens
in the middle of the animation,
it may be noticeable
to the user.
It'll just cause
a little hiccup there.
So that's just kind of
a general tip anyway,
but there's
another subtlety here
with GPU acceleration
that these objects,
the paints
and the bitmaps,
may be expensive
for us to create
because we're doing stuff
at the GPU level
of recreating these textures,
re-uploading the textures,
that you don't really want us
to do all the time.
So keep these objects around
and reuse them
as opposed to creating them
new every time.
A link to that is, don't modify
the bitmaps very often.
Every time you modify a bitmap,
even if it's just
a little bit of the bitmap,
we actually need to
upload a texture.
That tends to be an expensive
operation with GPUs.
So you may have not changed
much on that bitmap,
but we basically need to send
the entire thing over the GPU,
which is expensive.
So don't do it
if you don't need to.
Guy: It's actually a problem
we ran into,
I believe it was
in the web browser
during the development
of Android 3.0,
we noticed
that the frame rate
was not what
it was supposed to be and,
so we're, you know,
looking at the code
and said, "Web viewing,"
we're wondering why is the web
page so slow to render,
until we realized
that the tabs at the bottom--
at the top of the screen
were modifying a bitmap
on every single frame.
And we were spending,
actually, most of our time
just rendering the tab
at the top, not the page.
So that was an easy fix.
Haase: Actually,
it's really cool
to have bugs like that
during a release,
because then,
toward the end of the release,
you can make
a very simple fix,
and just
up the performance tremendously.
I--there--
[laughter]
there was an awesome
speed up that we had
in the animation system
because early on
in the development of
the animation framework,
I, you know, put in
an arbitrary value
that basically said,
"Okay, we're going to get
30 frames a second here."
And then,
a couple months later,
I'd forgotten
that I'd put this thing in,
and we're trying
to figure out,
"How come we can't get
to 60 frames a second?
Everything has been optimized.
We've tuned everything here."
And then,
I saw my little value there,
and I changed it
and I checked it in,
and we got 2x
the animation performance.
[laughter]
Pretty awesome.
Guy:
And actually, I've--
I have one more
little story like that.
The Maps application
tried hardware acceleration
and they were disappointed
by the--the results.
And it's back and forth
on the bug reporting.
We're wondering what's going on
because it didn't make sense.
I think it was taking, like,
taking 300 milliseconds
to load one frame, until
I finally used the Traceview,
which is an awesome tool
in the SDK,
and I realized that on every
frame when you scrolled the map,
they were reloading their XML,
their menu from XML, 96 times.
[laughter]
So that took
a little bit of time,
and it had nothing to do
with drawing.
And that happens
so many times.
Like, very often,
like, the kind of bug,
performance bugs that we have,
like, use Traceview
and look at how much time
you're spending drawing
and how much time you're
spending doing other stuff.
You'll be really surprised by
what's going on in applications.
So you can't always
blame the drawing.
Haase:
Was it Traceview I used
to trace down
the memory thing too?
The--
Was that--
Guy: LX?
Haase: Allocation tracker.
Guy: Yeah.
Haase: Also in the tools.
Very useful.
If the element I was mentioning
about animations
creating a little bit of garbage
and eventually getting a GC,
allocation tracker
in the tools in DDMS,
is very useful
for figuring out
what is actually being allocated
on the fly,
'cause it may not be obvious
from looking at your code,
but it is when you look
at the output of the tool.
Guy: So similar to not
modifying bitmaps too often,
if you're drawing your path
and you change the path
all the time,
if you remember the example
of the path
that we showed you
at the beginning
of the presentation,
we have this texture mask,
and to generate
that texture mask,
we have
to upload a texture
and we have to render the path
inside the texture.
So if you change the path
on every frame,
we'll have to regenerate
the texture on every frame,
and it will be
the equivalent
of modifying
the bitmap on every frame.
If your path
is relatively small,
it's going to be just fine,
but be very careful
if you have a really large path
that's pretty much,
you know,
half the size of the screen
or more.
Avoid overdraw.
This is extremely important
with the GPU because,
I mean, we all think,
that, you know,
that GPUs are
this awesome things
that can run the 3-D games,
but games are
really well optimized
to draw each pixel
once if they can.
It's much harder to do that
with a UI
where we have several layers,
and very often,
we have anti-aliasing
and translucency,
and so we have to draw
each layer.
There's nothing
we can skip.
So to give you an idea
on the current generation GPUs,
you can render about 2.5 times
the number of pixels onscreen
per frame and run
at 60 frames per second.
So if you draw
a background image
and you draw a second
background image on top of it
and you can't see the one
that was behind, like,
you have a background texture
and then you put a white
rectangle on top of it,
that's already
two times
the number of pixels onscreen,
and you only--
and most of your frame rate
is gone.
And actually,
that's one of the optimizations
we did in some of our apps.
We have a default background
texture in Android 3.0
and some of the apps
were just covering it.
And they were losing
a lot of frame rate
just because
they were not removing
that background texture.
We have some optimizations
to take care of it.
They cannot
always be applied.
So make sure that you draw
only what you have to draw.
And finally, we just told you
a few stories.
If there's one thing
you should take away
from this presentation
is profile your application.
We have tools in the SDK.
We have DDMS and Traceview.
Use them.
They will give you a lot of
really cool information
about what's going on
in your app,
and very often,
you may be surprised
by what's going on.
It's not necessarily
your fault.
Sometimes it's, you know,
you're calling an API
and you don't realize
that this very simple API,
just one line of code
is going to do
something very expensive.
So if you have any doubts
about the performance
of your application,
run Traceview, run DDMS,
and go to the talk
this afternoon about the tools.
That's about it for today.
If you want more information,
there's an article
that recaps all of this on
"d.android.com,"
the official development
website for Android.
We also post technical articles
from time to times
on our personal blogs,
and we have times--
time for Q&A,
so if you have questions,
please come to the mics.
Haase: And that's the end
of the main talk, anyway.
[clapping]
Thank you.
Yep?
man: So quick question.
So in the hardware
acceleration thing
you generate shaders.
Have you found any benefit
compiling those shaders
for the individual GPUs?
Guy:
Compiling them to--?
man: Compiling them,
for example,
I know PowerVR offers
a GL/SL compiler.
Have you found
any benefit there,
or is it just good enough
to hand it off to the driver?
Guy: I mean, the driver
will do the compilation.
We thought about
caching the results.
The problem is,
caching the result
of a shader compilation
is a proprietary extension.
Haase:
Right.
Guy: And, for instance,
the one that NVIDIA offers
has severe limitations,
like it takes--
it contains the
cron blend mode.
So we decided against it
because it was too complicated
and it didn't offer
any real benefit for us.
man: So are you talking
about caching the result
from on the on device
compilation
or actually compiling it?
Guy:
From the on device compilation.
man:
Okay.
Guy: We can't afford to do--
We're going to run on so many
devices that we can't do the--
compilation
ahead of time.
man: I--I just didn't know
if you were--
Guy: Yeah, sure.
No, no.
man: Yeah.
And another question.
Romain, what's your score
on Stack Overflow?
Guy: My score?
Uhhhh, I don't know.
I can look if you want.
Haase: He cheats anyway.
He totally votes up
his own answers.
man: Well, I don't know how
you get any work done.
I mean, every time
I Google an Android problem,
I--it's all--
It's honestly like that's,
I might as well just Google
"problem + Romain," so anyways.
Guy: I just don't sleep
very much.
man: Okay.
Fair enough.
man: Hi.
Do you know, with 3.0,
is it possible to get
hardware acceleration
of the HTML5 Canvas element
in the browser
when you're drawing to it?
Guy:
No, it's--it does--
it's one of the few things
that it doesn't do,
but I know that the browser team
has plans for that.
man:
Okay.
Haase: And our Q&A
is going to be cut short
because we were very late
in starting,
so we will probably go
a couple more minutes here
and we're going to be
in and out of office hours,
which is go across the hall
and upstairs.
man: So one thing
I noticed while using fragments
is when you add fragments or
if you're replacing fragments,
in Honeycomb,
the animation is just terrible.
It stutters a lot
and, you know,
it kind of tries
to hide
one of the fragments
and kind of readjusts the size
and starts to show
the other fragment
and it's really slow.
I mean, why is that?
And I'm not using
any custom animations
on the fragments.
Guy: That sounds weird
because, I mean,
we use Fragments
in a similar application
and we don't have
these issues.
So that's why
you should profile.
So profile the application
and try to see where
the time is spent,
and then you can probably
do stuff like enable
hardware layers or try to reduce
the number of views
you have to improve
the performance.
I mean, it's great
to run on the GPU,
but GPUs have
their limitations.
If you give us
too much work to do,
we'll happily send it
to the GPU, but, you know,
it's going to choke on it.
Haase: It could be
that the fragment
is doing something like,
you know,
the animation that's happening
is resizing the fragment
and if you have
a really complex layout,
well, resizing it is going to
cause a layout on every frame.
man: I don't have
a very complex layout.
It's a simple list
which, I mean,
even the list items itself
is just, like, you know,
probably just text
or probably just two lines--
two text labels.
Guy: Have you turned on
the hardware acceleration?
man: Yes, of course.
Guy: Okay.
Then profile
the application.
See what's going on.
man:
Okay.
Guy: You know, file bugs
if it's awful.
man: And the other question
I had is, I mean,
why do you need to turn on
hardware acceleration?
Why can't the system be--
Guy: I mean,
that's pretty obvious.
I mean, we showed
the limitations.
Like, we can't guarantee
100% compatibility of the--
with the apps,
so if you have an app on market
and we turn on the hardware
acceleration for you
but it makes your app crash,
then your users won't be
very happy with you,
and it's going to be
our fault.
So we don't want
that to happen.
man: Shouldn't it be transparent
to the user
if a hardware acceleration
is turned on automatically?
Haase: It can't be transparent
to the user
if we don't support something
that the application depends on,
and we don't know that
the application depends on it.
Right? So we could either
opt in--we could either
opt in everybody by default
and end up really messing up
some applications that weren't
doing anything wrong
to begin with.
man: Right.
Haase: Or we could have you
choose to opt-in
after you test
your applications,
which is probably
a more robust model.
Guy: But, our goal
is somehow, someday to,
you know,
make it a default.
Haase:
Yeah.
man: Because, I've seen
that there are lots of--
Haase: Sir, Sorry.
If you can catch us later.
man: I'll catch you later.
Haase: We can't debug it
anymore from there,
but, we'll take
one more question
and then we should
shut this down.
man:
Yeah, sorry.
I apologize if this was covered,
but was there any enhancements
that would benefit apps
that still have to target
older platforms?
Like 1.6 and up,
let's say.
Guy:
So yeah.
If you target an older platform,
you will have to do
some trickery to enable
hardware acceleration,
but that's doable,
and if you're--
we can't simply
optimize the framework,
so if you don't use the hardware
acceleration, you know,
we try to make
the software pipeline faster.
I can't give you
any number, but--
man: So I would
be able to
add the line in the manifest
and that still would work,
and then reflection?
Guy: Yeah. Yes, if your target--
If you change
your target SDK to 11,
you can add
the attributes,
or you can do it from code,
you know,
you can have a special case,
like, if you're running
on Honeycomb then...
man:
Turn it on?
Guy: You can run
that line of code.
man: Okay.
Thanks.
Haase: And that's it.
Thank you.